it's not by chance that it happens to be
that
uh fairfax and l.a kind of became a
streetwear capital
over the last like 15 to 20 years it's
not by chance it's because
of diversity you know it's just that's
what streetwear has
always stood for and that's where
strength came from hey this is bobby
hundreds with
vr kicks and this is behind the design
the hundreds simple straightforward side
of things it's a
clothing brand um we used to say a men's
streetwear brand but i think even those
boundaries and
lines and that genre has been challenged
and
re-established so we it's a clothing
company for
everyone and i think i was always drawn
to streetwear
well first i have to also establish that
street where
when we were starting out it wasn't
called street where uh there wasn't
really an industry or marketplace around
it there was clothing for
young people and youth culture but there
wasn't anything like
really like the street streetwear that
we know today street where these young
brands and artists of the time of the
mid 90s and the early 90s
and the late 90s they really spoke to me
because they were kind of um
cross-genre they uh were
for every or more inclusive even though
it's a very exclusive
sector of clothing it's also in many
ways
inclusive in the sense of you know it's
not just for
you know at the time late 90s early
2000s it was like black or white kids it
was just like they called it urban
which was code for black and white which
was like really like skateboarding
action sports related and um i didn't
fit
neatly into either of those categories
and so
i was drawn to these brands because it
was just really more about the art
and really more about reaching out to
all different types of communities
yeah so le28 is this program it's a cast
of
characters of artists entertainers
personalities athletes olympians who
have contributed did in many ways
in their own personal ways into what the
logo looks like for the
los angeles olympics in 2028 and
as you know with every olympics there is
a big rollout around
what the iconography or the logo set
looks like
and this time around they didn't want to
go with just one static
logo or one static identity they wanted
it
to reflect the nuance of la and the
diversity of la
they invited me to be one of the artists
involved and
my piece of it was making an a that also
reflected
on again like my favorite part of la
when i think of it what makes us
so strong and unique is our diversity
and so
it's a bunch of these cartoon hands
which i often draw a lot
and flowers that bloom from those hands
and
i think it's our greatest strength and
la has really proven to be this
classic illustration of what it looks
like when different
people and different communities can
coexist
work together and actually become
greater than the sum of its parts i feel
like we've been leading the pack in
terms of tech
art food culture and
streetwear you know and it's not
by chance that it happens to be that uh
fairfax and l.a kind of became a
streetwear capital
over the last like 15 to 20 years it's
not by chance it's because
of diversity you know it's just that's
what streetwear has always
stood for and that's where strength came
from
[Music]
i've i mean look it's massive just to
work alongside and with the olympics
it's that's a career milestone i think
for
most everybody we try to do work that
is timeless and lives outside of the
walls of
you know the current context and to
think of
like there's nothing more timeless than
the olympics like they run throughout
history and so it will
outlive me which is a cool feeling um
this project specifically also is really
meaningful because
it's technically an eight-year project
like we're starting
to promote in 2020 what will happen in
2028
and i juxtapose that with the lifespan
of
my children i have two young boys who
um are you know i
very much made them a part of the
process i sat with them as i was drawing
the my piece of the logo and i wanted
them really cognizant and aware of what
i was working on
so that in eight years when they're
late teens and we go to the olympics
together and they
see you know the iconography up
they can say i was there with my dad
when we were kids and young and worked
on that and now
you know i'm an adult and so in mirrors
their entire youth in their childhood
hey this is bobby hundreds with br kicks
and thanks for watching behind the
design